costa qui a choisi lui-même les vedettes
de son programme des inconnus joël
favreau et victoria regardez le monde
s'agite heures et paraître mon habit
l'imposture
et de supercherie on peut être mendiants
et orgueilleux
être porté ses guenilles sans en être
pour rire
pour
qui est victoria c'est une anglaise
victoria font-elles des chansons que
tout un parfum parfum du pays revient
même à l'opposé de ce que je suis ce tir
on appuie brume un pays où il faut
secourir l'hiver
messi lui que j'épouserai
le sera sûrement
demain
quant à joël fait la connaît depuis
qu'ils étaient tout petits stérile avait
à peu près la même apparence quand j'ai
su qu'ils écrivaient les chansons
quelques fois pendant les spectacles que
je faisais je m'arrêter ou de la 10ème
chansons et je disais sans nous prévenir
je vais vous chanter quelques chansons
sous mais alors au milieu de votre
spectacle vous dit tout d'un coup
monsieur at-elle vaches en vous sentez
une chanson est le régisseur
l'éclairagiste tout le monde ne s'affole
pas en disant mais c'était pas du tout
ça ça lui fait une
c'était une mise en condition qui s'est
effectuée progressivement c'est à dire
que lorsque j'ai décidé d'accepter des
servitudes et les joies de chanter je
tenais à ce qui est plus de joie que de
servitude et ces noms 7
cette optique que j'ai pu je peux
arriver à chanter depuis
bientôt deux ans et demi sans fatiguer
avec beaucoup de plaisir mais je crois
que c'est ça c'est l'art je veux dire un
lieu commun un peu grandiloquent mais
l'art recréer la vie si ma vie est faite
comme ça il faut quand je suis sur un
plateau je cependant on put et de cette
possibilité
la fantasy viii lise c'est ce qui me
motive c'est absolument nécessaire qui
concerne votre slogan ça serait
l'improvisation mais pas la pagaille
alors vous avez dû vous sentir un peu
prisonnier quand vous avez tourné le
film mendiants et orgueilleux
on vous débuté au cinéma comme comédien
mais j'avais pourtant pris beaucoup de
précautions saveur que j'ai choisi le
sujet le rôle le lieu est même une
certaine manière de tourner par exemple
je tenais beaucoup à ce que ce soit fait
l'extérieur on soit leur sert aussi à
cinq minutes de pause que je puisse
prendre un match à la rue pour nos
métiers aller au café ne pas être à
l'ombre d'un studio
qu'est ce que ce personnage un
personnage est un homme qui aime vivre
qui a de l'humour et qui a du
détachement et sans être lui j'ai
quelque chose de commun vous aimez vivre
je vais vous avez de l'humour j'espère
vraiment je l'espère je ne veux pas
quitter le sens de l'humour et du
détachement pour une certaine quantité
de choses je pense pas être capable de
me détacher du tout à quoi êtes vous
attaché on se sont serrés la nation se
fait par une série de petites choses qui
vous semblent indispensables ne fut-ce
que l'horizon de travail et j'aime
beaucoup travaillé je me rendis serait
que l'autre à lyme me plaît mais j'ai
une idée très hot de la paresse mais
vous aimeriez n'a rien faire du tout
j'ai connu ça
souvenirs de l'oise éviter complète
c'était un geste et on fait plein de
choses quand on ne fait rien ce qui
change c'est que c'est inattendu alors
vous ne met plus la paresse je le
laissais de la donne en cours dans mon
comportement c'est dire que l'appareil
soit une que mon goût de la paresse soit
neutralisèrent de musique c'est si ma
vie était autre chose de travail ne
manquerez pas parce que le sol est
rempli d'autres choses vous savez de
quoi sert la blonde amour c'est dans le
sens le plus large c'est un amour de
l'amour des livres